why is going viral a bad thing I think
it's not a bad thing it's only bad if
you take the wrong indicators from it I
think it was MKBHD who said the best
thing that never happened to me was
having an early video go viral if you
have a video that goes viral it's your
first one or your second one and the
process was terrible you didn't like it
but then you just take that as an
indicator of that's exactly what I
should do you're going to find yourself
in a life that you don't like so I think
it's just about having the understanding
of the lifestyle you want if and when
virality comes I think sometimes uh
virality turns you into someone who is
uh constantly seeking that outcome of
virality and um I think the the thing to
seek is the process right and so that
that's that's my opinion of like I think
as creators we should be seeking a a
better more enjoyable process not
necessarily the
outcome